warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised so I'm praying
silently to the Holy Spirit what do I do
next and I heard the Holy Spirit say
it's just
hiding and so it didn't leave leave so
it didn't leave it pretended to leave
right and so I I called its name and as
soon as I called its name it took
possession of her again oh and this time
was using her hands in a Chim dance
fashion yeah and then pointed at the
roof of our building building directly
above and said the ruling Spirit at
anawat Anka's the temple nearby us is
angry with you and immediately a bolt of
lightning hit right above oh wow and
Rain came in horizontally oh wow I've
never seen rain come in this direction
before hey everybody Welcome to LED live
today we are going to discuss a scary
topic or at least topic that you don't
see um mentioned or talked about enough
from Ministries and uh maybe it's
perhaps we don't know how to deal with
this thing so you're going to want to
stick through this one Tim Maddox is
here to join us all the way from
Cambodia thank you we're excited to hear
what you have to say I have met Tim in
various different parts of the world um
first time I think it was Philippines
yes and uh second time I got a chance to
speak at a youth convention with him in
Malaysia and so he has a Ministry that
you speak on Deliverance and this is
what we're going to discuss today
demonic spirits are real and they do
torture people and I think you know it's
a really strange thing that we don't
really talk about it as often as
probably we should in this country but
maybe we don't see it as openly in this
country well sure Jesus told us well
told his disciples that they would to go
and preach the gospel and while they're
doing that that they were to heal the
sick and one of the things he said cast
out evil spirits so we're doing the
ministry that Jesus called us to do we
should be casting out evil
spirits this is a very sensitive topic
and so I want to do something that you
guys don't normally see us do um we pray
before we start these shows but you we
we you don't see that aspect of this but
I would really like to pray today um for
this conversation I think this is an
important conversation
and not something that should be trifled
with in a I mean we should approach it
with reverence let's pray dear gracious
Heavenly Father we thank you for this
opportunity to talk with Mr Maddox here
and that he is going to bless us with
this ministry that you've given to him
and um potentially give us some some
guidance and some advice on how to deal
with um spiritual warfare in a very real
um sense because I believe that these
things are going to happen more
frequently and so we thank you for this
opportunity please protect this room
keep any evil spirits out of this room
as we discuss this and Lord may this be
a blessing to all that hear it we love
you and thank you in Jesus name amen
amen all right Mr Maddox tell us a
little bit about uh what how did you get
into this give us a little backstory so
a as a teenager I uh would have to go
through the city of Perth in West
Australia to go home after school and I
love to go into bookshops well one day I
walked into a Bookshop without actually
looking at what they sell by the time I
got to the back of the Bookshop I was
feeling nauseous I had a headache I was
feeling weak and this is like less than
30 seconds from when I worked into the
shop interesting and I started to look
and I realized I had walked into a shop
selling books on witchcraft wow oh wow
and I turned around and got out of that
shop quickly and as soon as I got out
that experience of feeling nauseous and
dizzy left me oh wow and so as a
teenager I realized that there are
strong spiritual Powers Yeah and I later
at the age of 21 was working in Samo as
a teacher at an Adventist school and one
of our students kept getting what we
found out to be demon-possessed he'd
become zombie like he'd get angry with
somebody and then he'd become zombie
like super strong so he was a teenager
he was a teenager and uh he would be
basically unconscious he wouldn't talk
but he could still walk what interesting
like had no recollection was blacking
out so on what was happening he wouldn't
know what would happened wow wow and so
we took him to the doctors and the
doctor said oh he's studying too
hard of course he's not demon possessed
he's just studying but uh the principal
and I we felt No this must be demon
possession so we'd never been taught on
Deliverance but we prayed over him and
we ordered the evil spirits out in the
name of Jesus just like it reads in the
Bible and he was set free wow and so
this was my first experience um was it
kind of like the movies their convol
scene something crawled up on the
ceiling upside down no it was turn his
head turned around nothing like that
happened it didn't look like you
expected it to look yeah um I didn't
have any
expectations but we were just grateful
that God honored his word that when we
order evil spirits out in the name of
Jesus the spirit left him once we
ordered that evil spirit out he was just
normal again and to my knowledge he
never had had another attack interesting
did he recognize it or you have a
discussion with him about it and was it
something that that he was like okay and
shared some information maybe how that
even transpired in the first place this
was 38 years ago so I've actually
forgotten some of the details okay but
this is what got you into this yes
experience yes how old are you about
this time about 21 22 years of age okay
so yeah young enough to be like wow like
what do I do with this yeah and and and
did you begin to then explore like okay
what is this and how does this work no
actually I had nothing else to do with
this until I uh was in Fiji and again
teaching and one night I was on Library
Judy and somehow I upset one of the
students from the Solomon Islands and he
grabbed me around the throat and pinned
me to a desk and as I looked into his
eyes I could see riblets of fire running
out of his eyes I had seen that in
advertisements for horror movies and I
saw it real oh uh later on some of the
girls told me they had seen this guy in
the dorm at night walk through walls
holding a fetish oh and so he had
demonic power wow walking through walls
isn't that crazy that's crazy but it
that's what they told me so bizarre see
I wonder if that stuff really happens
here like I mean you guys are from
different countries okay so so it
happened to me do you hear about that I
when I was younger so I didn't grow up
in a Christian household my dad would
frequently turn on ACDC Health Bells
Highway to Hell let zling like the whole
shabam right grw up in that kind of
house and so imagine you walk down the
stairs he's cooking it's like Hells
Bells like that so I became a Christian
like 15 16 and it was around that time
that I started seeing wacky things you
know I remember just like taking a bath
and we had this you know like the steam
showers that have like the control
buttons and stuff and I was just looking
at at the shower and all of a sudden the
control panel had moved like right in
front of my eyes I was like what and
then I realized the control panel I saw
in the first place wasn't even the one
that normally is there like was a
completely different control panel it it
was it just
shifted and so different things like
that um and you know my mom and I were
getting ready to church she was standing
in the opposite side of the room and I
was drying my hair and she turns around
she's like did you touch me I was like
no I'm right here she's like something
touched me she was in church her seat
start shaking she looks around
everybody's fine so weird things like
that that and I grew up in a a secular
society but I really believe because of
the things that we listen to as a family
growing up that it invited something
into our home and including my mom is
from South Africa I went to Africa
bought one of those uh face masks that
the that the you know um black South
Africans have my aunt told me they're
like careful with that because they pray
and invite spirits to go into that and I
didn't know any better so I have it in
my home and there was a time we felt
convicted we should get rid of all of
our books we still had like Harry Potter
books in the Attic you know like didn't
really throw them out we were like we
have to throw it out I pick up the mask
and this like dark feeling comes over me
you know I'm like okay there's something
about this and I don't think we have to
be scared of objects or of demons but we
do need to be careful with what invited
to our home when I first moved to
Hollywood I was 21 years old and now I
was about 192 and um I was in my
apartment by myself I would often um um
intoxicate and then I would sit down and
watch a movie or whatever it was just
kind of a little Pastime that I would do
and um I can still remember this clear
as a bell I I I want to ask God about
this when I get to heaven um I was
standing in my kitchen and I felt
something come into the room just like
kind of what you're describing you know
as a human you just you know something's
not correct right and and I couldn't see
it it was standing right behind me and
it was almost like one of those things
like as you turn around it's like just
in your peripheral view behind you but
you can never really kind of see it in
in your frontal face and and and I can
remember um I just come to Hollywood I
wanted to be an actor I had just gotten
an agent I was going out on all these
auditions and stuff like this and this
entity asked me would you give up
salvation for the fame wow
and I don't know remember how I answered
like I really don't I I think I said no
I hope I said no but I actually don't
remember because it was 10 years before
God really won my heart back and and and
I got out of that situation and then re
recalling back I mean I can still
remember the experience but um I don't
remember how I answered it I hope I told
him no yeah I mean you're here today
right yeah right maybe that's why I
never ever I me I was a terrible actor I
couldn't anything anyway but yeah I've
even had these experiences going on a
mission trip in Iceland I was there uh
with a youth young adult
organization they told me about this
garden with like statues and stuff that
was attached to a Catholic church and
they were like there's something funky
about this I was super skeptical I was
like yeah whatever and so like we go to
we walk past it because we were prayer
walking the city uh of raiku viic and I
kid you not I take set one step one foot
on the first um Step into the garden and
this I felt like gravity had pushed me
down it sounds like it's familiar to you
right so I walk in and and I see all
these demonic looking statues that were
supposedly Christian or Catholic and
they look full-on demonic and I'm just
like what is in this place this is weird
and I was still feeling a little cocky
and I'm like I'm just going to walk off
you know whatever and I felt the Holy
Spirit talking to me don't walk away
from the group I was like okay I'm not
playing around with this I hear you I
say it with the group I set one foot
outside the garden and it left wow it
was crazy but it sounds like you're
saying like you're familiar with that
yeah if I can tell your story so I moved
to Cambodia in
1992 and in Cambodia they are Buddhist
but we say Buddhist skin deep underneath
that they are animist so they are
worshiping the spirits they're
worshiping idols and demons and these
are like and centuries back this has
been happening yeah and so my wife is
running a we call it a bush clinic so
she's not a doctor but she was doing her
best to help people with their medical
needs and this lady comes and she had
come to us directly from a Cambodian
witch doctor and the witch doctor had
assumed she had evil spirits in her and
taking taken a burning incense stick and
burned her 32 times on the chest oh wow
wow and so she had all these little
Burns that were getting infected oh wow
and anyway my wife listened to a story
and my wife called me and said this
one's your patient
yeah and so as I discuss with her the
situation she would get controlled by
demons and uh she obviously was looking
for freedom and she had had a dreadlock
now we think of dreadlocks and we think
of Bob Marley right yeah uh and but in
Cambodia if you have a dreadlock it's
almost a sign that demons are possessing
you interesting why why is that is it
because the dreadlocks people are
associated with dreadlocks are
associated with what is the Rel
Rari not in
Cambodia it's just I I can imagine it's
just like you know there's there there's
rules I guess you could say that they
have to play by right and so there's
certain things that you can do that are
visual representations of like this
individual is is free game for us or we
have rights over them or whatever ever
like that I mean obviously God asking
Samson to not cut his hair like what's
what's really there's not power in the
hair but it was like a visual that was
like off limits to the to the you know
demonic world I don't know you know so I
see people getting dreadlocks put in
just for the look and to me like you if
you knew the background you wouldn't do
that what is the background do you know
I don't actually know I just every time
I've encountered dreadlocks in Cambodia
it's always been demon possession that
is fascinating I'm going to look that up
why that happen this lady told me she
would come out of dreadlock and within
24 hours it' be back again and it was in
the shape of a human male wow so I told
her okay get your husband to go to your
house and bring it and all the other
paraphernalia that's in any way involved
with worship which he did and when uh he
returned we were sitting in an sort of
open area two sides were open uh facing
to the north
and she unwrapped this dreadlock she had
had the monks cut it off the Buddhist
monks and they told her keep take care
of it so she'd been taken care of it and
I unwrapped well she unwrapped it and
she began pointing out the fact that it
was the figure of a male and her voice
changed to a male voice oh wow so I took
it from her and laid it on the floor and
as soon as I laid it on the floor this
giant green grasshopper flew in and
landed right on top of it mhm uh which
the students later told me that's
another
sign and then the grasshopper started
speaking like a
male but that would be weird we sat her
down and we began praying for her I had
a group of uh lay students who were
studying to be Bible workers and so we
prayed over her and when we stopped
praying over her the evil spirit the
male evil spirit started talking oh wow
and so we ordered the evil spirit out it
it identified itself um it had a name it
had a name it uh its name was Tay Tay is
an old character with a long beard and
has a walking stick similar sort of
personality to Santa Claus interesting
and uh anyway we kept ordering it out
and eventually after about 20 minutes
her leg shook and uh she came conscious
again so she was completely unaware of
what had happened in the last 20 minutes
w wow uh and this is like I don't know
what to do next right so I'm praying
silently to the Holy Spirit what do I do
next and I heard the Holy Spirit say
it's just
hiding and so it didn't leave leave it
didn't leave it pretended to leave right
and so I I called its name and as soon
as I called its name it took possession
of her again oh W and this time was
using her hands in a Chim dance fashion
yeah and then pointed at the roof of our
building directly above and said the
ruling Spirit at Anor what Anor what's
the temple nearby
is angry with you and immediately a bolt
of lightning hit right above oh wow and
Rain came in horizontally oh wow you
know I've never seen rain come in this
direction before I mean that's stuff
like out of the movies yeah yeah did
this freak you out no wow I mean you're
pretty solidly like no sorry my God's
stronger than yours so you know so is
that all you got sideway what's up buddy
now we had burned the dreadlock and the
other paraphernalia outside when we
started burning it the sky was blue with
just a little bit of cloud on the
horizon where anwa Temple is but this is
20 minutes later and now rain is coming
in horizontally our building's been hit
by a bolt of lightning wow and the
timing was Split Second timing so I knew
this was the devil trying to scare us so
we picked the lady up and carried her
into our treatment room and it was a
wooden Clapper board room and fine Mist
was coming between the boards the rain
was that heavy
and strong and we carried on ordering
the evil spirits out of her after about
15 minutes she shook violently all over
and she came around and said I saw a
little long haired person with their
hands tied behind their back walking
away from me wow so she's now free yeah
wow um the next day we were I was
counseling with her and I she told me
about a lump in her back about the size
of a marble and if she touched it it
would move up and down whoa seriously so
I asked about that and she said yes it's
still there so we prayed and then I
ordered the evil spirit that caused this
lump in her back to leave and
immediately an evil spirit started
talking wow and this time this Spirit
was a different Spirit uh and it said we
we will leave if her husband builds her
a builds them a house to live in so it's
very typical in Cambodia to see little
Spirit houses out in front of a house
and that's where the local Spirits can
live and people put offerings there to
keep them appeased and I immediately
said Jesus does not allow you to live in
the spirit house wow and told them in
the name of Jesus leave yeah they're
Liars so you know they're probably doing
whatever they can to stick around and if
you build a house that gives them the
full rain license to be probably you
know engaging with people all around
that
thing
so uh they left and this time she saw
two small humanlike beings with long
hair so so this is fascinating to me
because I mean think about The Adams
Family does they kind like a little
short hairy thing look like that yes
interesting I I I don't think people
understand these movies they think that
it's just fake and they don't realize
that many times these things are very
real Harry Potter you know we were
talking about this the other day she
specifically chose demonic names of real
demons that were really named that thing
and those are the characters that are in
there that's one of the books that we
grew up reading and had in our house and
we had this stuff happen to us yeah see
you've got their materials you've got
their things they got rain for you
you're inviting them in so with this
lady uh I was asking her about anger did
she get angry easily and she saides but
I'm only angry for a few minutes
immediately her husband broke out in
laughter he said when she gets angry
she's angry for days and so what I
realized was happening was anger was
like opening a door for the evil spirits
and they would come in and she would be
out of control for several days because
the evil spirits would be controlling
her when she came around she wouldn't be
aware of what's going on so she had no
memory of whenever she would get angry
or she wouldn't just call it she was
angry well at least in the experiences
we had with her she had no memory of
what happened while the evil spirits
were in control and that's really
interesting that they have like um sort
of an expertise in a particular
character trait right like there's a
demon of anger demon of like
intoxication demon of depression and
they are the ones that are actually like
you know suggesting things to you and it
was really interesting we had David Ang
Ang I think is how you say it David on
on the show and um he had talked about
um that you know we think of demons like
suggesting things to us and like you
know you're depressed you're depressed
and he said they actually speak in first
person so instead of saying you're
depressed the demon will just repeat in
your head I am depressed I am depressed
I am depressed I want to kill myself and
those thoughts given into x amount of
time you begin to think that they're
yours but they're not yours they are an
evil spirit that's suggesting things you
I think this a good point a good time to
talk about um the difference between uh
demonic oppression harassment and actual
possession so oppression uh could be
just feeling that heavy weight that you
felt on you right right uh harassment
would be where you're actually being
harassed by things moving around in your
room you're hearing voices you're seeing
uh things that aren't there but then
possession is when they're actually in
control and possession could be 24/7 as
in the demoniacs that Jesus cast evil
spirits out of or it could be
intermittent so they come and they go
and coming and going is the more typical
what what causes this what causes
full-on possession what causes demons to
harass you you know cuz you'd think well
I'm a Child of God like you know they
shouldn't be coming after me but they
do sin in the life gives them access so
if I can tell you another story I
was uh teaching another group of lay
people to be Bible workers and I taught
them on Deliverance Ministries and
usually when we do this God would send
somebody for the students to get actual
real life practice on well I'd finished
this session and it's like oh praise God
nobody came yeah because Deliverance
Ministry is never fun
no and I went home I had lunch and I get
a call from the students one of our
students is being attacked by evil
spirits so I go to the classroom and
he's rolling around on the floor
screaming in agony his arms and legs are
being Twisted in all different
directions and it's we can't see what's
doing it but it's obviously happening so
we gathered around him and we're doing
ordering the evil spirits out of him and
one of the older members of our group he
was in his 50s he came and knelt next to
me and he put his hands on the legs of
this young man who's rolling around
screaming in agony and he began to pray
and as uh he started to pray he started
to gag as if he's going to vomit the the
person praying praying yeah and so I I
looked at him and I see this gray Shadow
around him this is something I've never
seen before but I knew it's demonic sure
so I looked at the students on the
opposite side of the young man and said
take this one and pray for him so
basically we're dealing with two people
now and this older gentleman he
uh because he's got involved in
Deliverance but he's not clean of sin
the evil spirits have now attacked
him so after the young man set free I
went to the older gentleman and he's
still in his right mind but he's still
got the shadow around him and I asked
him
so what haven't you confessed cuz just a
couple of days before we'd uh talked
about confession and uh I sent my
students out for half an hour of talking
to the Holy Spirit about what they need
to confess and he hung his head and he
said um I hate my
father-in-law so he prayed and he asked
God to forgive him to take away the hate
and after he said I man I looked at him
and the Shadow's still there and so now
I'm praying silently Holy Spirit what is
it and the Holy Spirit says he loves to
control people m M and I looked at him
and said Is it true that you love to
control people wow he was a
policeman and he hung his head he said
yes and I said you need to confess that
and after he had confessed that the
shadow had gone
wow so harboring sin in our lives is
like opening a door for evil spirits to
come in they may not come in yeah but
the door is open and if they choose to
they could come in because sin separates
us from God the Bible says so if you're
separated from the one that protects you
and loves you and gives you life then it
opens the door for them and it doesn't
need to be like a a sin a commonly known
sin like the Ten Commandments you can
see a pattern here like uh hatred anger
Pride I mean controlling somebody
there's no there's no commandment with
that you know so to say well there is
The Ten Commandments are based on love
man and love others so that falls under
that that would be the spirit of the law
and and in order contr some you got to
have some pride yeah true like I know
better than what you know for
yourself of yourself you better do what
I tell you to do right yeah so we can go
back to this young man who's rolling
around in agony so we order the evil
spirit out and after a little while he
screams and he goes unconscious this is
classic biblical Deliverance first time
I'd ever seen it and uh a couple of
minutes later he comes around he's fine
but then maybe half hour hour later he's
attacked again this goes on over and
over again and at one point he cries out
there throwing Spears at me and he
starts coughing right bright red blood
oh wow as if his lungs have been
punctured oh wow and we didn't allow
that to distract us from what God has
called us to do so we continued ordering
the evil spirit out he cried out he went
unconscious he came around no blood the
blood's still sitting on the floor but
he was fine so is it an illusion does he
really have some medical issue going on
inside there was no real Spears or
anything right there's like no real
Spears the blood was real but there was
no I'd be curious that's his blood I
mean do they have some kind of way to
like give you the visual of like okay
yeah like Moses Moses and Aaron they
threw the rod they did the same thing
The Magicians we had to clean the blood
up but were those snakes that The
Magicians were doing were they I real
snakes I believe it wasn't real so it
was just an illusion like it was like
Satan is not a Giver of Life so he
cannot create life he can't create it
out of nothing yeah so so this young man
after a day and a half of this repeated
attacks I while he's in his right mind I
asked him so what did you do to get all
these evil spirits in you because it was
obvious there was like a legion of evil
spirits in him and he said well before I
became a Christian I used to sell drugs
I had killed a number of people
coldblooded wow but I had made a PCT
with evil spirits to take care of me wow
and so this was a conscious choice to
basically pray that a group of evil
spirits would protect him it didn't look
like they were protecting him yeah well
they were angry with him because he'd
become a Christian right he said I
thought when I was baptized that that
was done with but obviously baptism
alone wasn't enough to deal with it
right and uh so at the right time God
allowed those evil spirits to act up so
that they could be dealt with and um
that he could confess all that he's done
wrong and he could be delivered he went
on to be a church planner and to bring
people to Christ um so God set him
completely fre it reminds me of Roger
mono the guy who wrote the trip into the
supernatural you know he was involved in
Demon Cults and we did a couple shows on
on that topic um and the we had Chris l
that that had made a documentary about
this man's life and and very
interestingly um he would have the de
demonic spirits follow him around and
they would like kick trash cans and I
mean they're just annoying they just
annoy you throughout his life I think it
was all the way to the end he was still
being like you know they weren't
necessarily inside of him but they're
you know Haring doing things that are
trying to scare him or whatever cause a
reaction out of him and um you know must
be pretty amazing when you know that
they're there and you're just like you
can't touch me you know like my God's
stronger but once again you don't want
to be overly prideful about it I mean
think about the disciples right uh you
know I often wonder like you know Peter
sitting there going no Lord you're not
you don't have to go through that and
and and Jesus turns to him and says Get
Behind Me Satan like Satan was speaking
through Peter to give you know
discouragement to Jesus so I don't know
if that necessarily translate that
they're in inside of us so but how
common do you think that demon possess
possess harassment or like just
influence how common do you think it is
for like people the average
person I think it's a lot more common
than most of us want to admit we don't
recognize it well most people don't want
to talk about it we're afraid that
people are going to make fun of us we
start telling someone I'm hearing voices
or I'm seeing things mhm you know
they're going to laugh at us they going
to tell you go to a psychiatric hospital
MH um where is it is real MH uh and it
can be dealt with if people understand
that uh God will forgive all sins if we
confess it he is faithful and just to
forgive sins and so if we will confess
the sin that we've committed then uh and
claim the blood of Jesus to close the
doors that the evil spirits have been
using to access us then we can we can be
free but we need to remain in Christ
every day we need to be asking Christ to
be Lord Of Our Lives amen otherwise the
evil spirits will come back and Jesus
says it in Matthew 18 about when an evil
spirit leaves uh it'll wander around if
it doesn't find somewhere else looking
for something else look for some someone
else and then it'll come back and if the
house is clean and empty I think that's
the key word there we haven't the person
hasn't allowed Christ to come in and
occupy their life then the evil spirit
will go and find seven more and come
back and things will be worse this is
one reason I don't want to do
Deliverance for people that don't come
and ask you know you'll see crazy people
and you know they got demons in them uh
but I don't want to actually just walk
up and cast it out because it might
actually be worse for that person if
they don't accept Christ they might come
in with a few more yeah they're upset or
something you know made them leave yeah
so so you mentioned uh one of the things
that can cause someone to be what you
said harassed oppressed or possessed is
sin and we talked a little bit about you
know like at least in my life you you
were working in Hollywood and that's if
you watch our videos you know that's
full of demonic stuff for me it was
growing up in a household with Harry
Potter and like all this crazy music um
what's something else that can cause
someone to be experiencing this so
people coming out of a um animist
background or where Idols Deon uh Idols
are
worshiped they may have ancestors that
were priests sort of spirit priests
witch doctors and what I understand is
that the evil spirits that help them do
the magic they do are generational so
they move from one generation to the
next usually to the
firstborn and so often you know
Generations down the line people are
being harassed I met a young Indian lady
uh in Australia she was a dedicated
Adventist but her grandfather had been a
spirit priest and she would often
experience things being thrown around
her
room and she obviously was Adventist she
was actually attending a bible school
she hadd given a year of her life to
serving the lord before looking at what
to do next but the evil spirits are
still harassing her um and that there's
a generational thing there which need to
be broken by claiming the blood of Jesus
to break the pack that sometime in the
ancestral past has been made with the
evil spirits interesting so that it no
longer continues so like you said
baptism is not enough that's not
breaking the pack you actually have to
pray and say Lord break the pack even
though I've given my life to you it
appears to be the case yes so it's a
conscious severing of the rights that
the evil spirits claim I like that you
keep bringing the concept out about
confession
I think that's the you know the key that
actually gives them or breaks away their
strongholds or or whatever ability they
they have to stay there and and you know
we all need to confess things I mean
think about the things even in your
earlier childhood or your teenage years
or your college Years that you have not
confessed um and and just go over there
as you lay there in bed and you
contemplate the things that God has done
done for you and just go you know God
I'm really sorry that I I did that and
I'm really sorry that you know when I
was in my early 20s I did not put you
first I put me first or whatever you
know and like um just get in the habit
of asking for confession and and before
you if I say it this way do Deliverance
before you attempt to cast evil spirits
out in the name of Jesus make sure your
life is right with Christ okay so let's
talk about that for a second because um
conversations that I've had with other
people who have been in the room when
these demons come out when they come out
they'll start talking to you I mean is
there Rules of Engagement like they
can't necessarily address you unless you
address them or like how how how does
that work that they come out because
I've heard of them coming out and
starting going to he's got hatred in his
heart she's got this in this calling
stuff out I mean yeah I've never
actually experienced that but I always
try to make sure that the team that is
working with me uh have done deep
confession um but I've also heard of
others having that happen so when they
come out they may come out silently you
know so some people they demon possessed
and we pray over them asking God to
bless them to fill them and to we order
the evil spirit out in the name of Jesus
uh we don't converse with them so we
don't want to have a conversation with
them because you said already they're a
liar they're Li they're not going to
tell you anything truthful and they're
smart as well right yeah they have a lot
of practice um so they may just come out
quietly or they may go screaming yeah
and it always it always interested me
when Jesus you know like cast the demons
out and they start running up to him and
they're like oh you know you son of high
what do you have to do with us Jesus the
the you know honored of God like how why
would they do that um I think that's
because the individual still has a right
and so when the demoniac came running to
Jesus I think that's the the person
himself he's looking for freedom but
when he gets there it's the demons that
speak and I had an experience like this
where
a a fairly new
Christian uh his family were very upset
with him because he become Christian and
they were doing all sorts of
incantations and stuff to try to turn
him back so he came to us and he was not
feeling well and eventually he became
I'd just say crazy mhm and uh he ran off
he told me that actually Satan is
actually Jesus and Jesus is Satan people
just got it confused so interesting uh
he ran off uh into the fields and the
next day his relatives found him they
ran him down they tied him up like a pig
and hung him on a pole cuz he was so
wild and They Carried him back strung up
on a pole oh my and uh when they got him
back he was uh tied up on the road in
front of our classroom room and they
called me and I said to him do you want
Jesus help and immediately he said yes
no so he said yes the evil spirits said
no and my response was to the students
you heard him he said yes take him in
and one of the evil one of the students
ordered the evil spirit out in the name
of Jesus and it left and he was
perfectly peaceful we handed him the
Bible and opened to Psalms and he read
it perfectly well and we knew that he
was free so let's let's talk about this
for a second because I think that you
know there is a thing slain in the
spirit people are doing this and and
when you see you know them supposedly
casting a a a holy spirit into you right
they're flopping around they're crying
they're passing out and all that kind of
stuff so so why I wanted to bring that
up is because what you're describing
when a spirit like leaves you and and
and obviously hopefully you're you're
you're inviting Jesus in in that moment
that's what the peace and all that is
coming in it's a peace it's a calmness
it's a rightful
mindedness not speaking gibberish and
you know rolling around for hours
laughing and and you know crazy things
like that that to me sounds more what
the Demonic world is doing than what the
Holy Spirit does it's true so a lady I
dealt with in a neighboring Village she
came to me because she was speaking in
tongues and she didn't couldn't
translate it but she could speak it she
could sing it she could write it and her
husband was threatening to divorce her
because he found that embarrassing and
so she came to me to ask if if this is a
a proper language and so I said oh we'll
come over to your house and we'll pray
with you and we'll deal with the
spiritual things in your house that are
not to the glory of God she was not an
Adventist but she was looking for help
so I went to a house with a fellow
Christian and uh we gathered all the
things together that were there in the
house and burn them uh that were related
to the spirits in any way and then I
prayed over her and asked God to set her
free and then I ordered the evil spirit
to leave her so I just said in the name
of Jesus evil spirit leave and I did
this for a couple of minutes just
repeating nothing happened and then I
stopped and said did you feel anything
and she said yeah I feel real
uncomfortable inside so I said okay
we'll do this again and this time I said
evil spirit that causes this lady to
speak in tongues leave her and
immediately she started talking with a
much younger voice talking really fast
the language I didn't understand but it
was very beautiful to listen to
interesting and but is it like a
gibberish or something no no it wasn't
gibberish it was it was it was very like
almost like you'd be listening to French
or something like that like it sounds
sounds like a real language and uh she's
crying like this young lady spirit is
crying and uh I just kept ordering it to
leave and after 2 minutes it left and
the joy of this lady she said this is
the first time in 18 years I have not
been able to think and that that
language is there it's gone wow now she
had told me that she could also um if
she cursed somebody whatever she cursed
would happen to them if she cursed them
to death within 3 days they would die
wow and she also told me that they could
she could tell a person's future for
within 3 or 4 days of uh when they asked
and so I said okay we need to deal with
this too so I ordered those Spirits out
as well in the name of Jesus and they
all left her wow and she was very very
thankful so how does the process like do
you have like a specific prayer does a
prayer have to have a certain structure
to like cast out a demon or because I'm
I'm guessing you just don't go in and
say you know get out of him there's like
a whole prayer or you have to say in the
name of Jesus so usually we will
obviously pray to God the Father for
this person and for his power to work on
that person's behalf and having done
that then we will speak directly to the
demon claiming the name of Jesus Jesus
for uh telling that demon to leave but
there is a case which I dealt with where
I didn't have time to do that uh a young
lady had come to an Evangelistic Series
in pomen and I had noted that she was
very
enthusiastic um she had gathered a group
of young guys together and she was
telling them that people in the church
are asleep they need to wake up Jesus is
coming message is excellent but there
was something wrong when I looked into
her eyes
the pupils of her eyes were glowing
sapphire blue oh interesting so I'm in
charge of the prayer tent I I couldn't
do anything there and the next day I see
her sitting with her sister alone so I
went and sat down and talked to her and
she told me the same message but her
eyes are still glowing and the following
day I see her she's got uh Elder Mike
Ryan who's the speaker at the
Evangelistic event he she's bailed him
up she wants to get up on the stage and
talk to everybody and
Elder Mike Ryan didn't speak Chim and
she didn't speak English so I went up
and said I'll I'll deal with it and I
began to lead her away talking to her
and I felt demonic oppression something
like you described earlier that heavy
weight pushing down on you and I just
looked at her and said evil spirit in
the name of Jesus leave immediately I
lost my voice and I could just whisper I
saw at that point I saw Pastor Scott
Griswald another expatriate missionary
there he had also experienced in this
and I motioned to him to come over and
um we led the girl to the prayer tent
where we had a prayer season for her her
sister came and said we got to go and
took her away before we had chance to
speak to her and so for 24 hours I'm
left wondering what have I done this
girl's a coming along to an Evangelistic
Crusade she's not yet
Christian and uh I've ordered an evil
spirit out of her and there was no
evidence of from what I
felt so 24 hours later I'm in the prayer
tent and she shows up and the first
thing she said to me was how did you
know I had a demon in me wow her eyes
were normal and she was free so she
recognized that there was something
inside of her yes it's interesting that
sometimes they disguise as you know good
stuff Christian stuff like like you were
talking about speaking in tongues you
know their Christians who are going to
think that's a gift from God and then
you know the spirit of uh the the gift
of Prophecy saying hey we got to wake up
you know Jesus is coming soon but how do
you how do you know how can you
different differentiate what is from God
and what is not a good question talking
to the Holy Spirit and listening for
guidance from the holy spirit in every
situation good point so you're
constantly just throwing prayers up and
you're talking yes you know through the
experience and stuff Have you ever been
in a group where where you know maybe
somebody didn't do something crazy but
you walked by and you you just kind of
went there's something in that
one yeah I didn't tell you this
experience but when I was 14 I was
sitting in the foyer of a psychiatric
ward in the main hospital in Perth West
Australia my mother worked as a psych
nurse in that Ward and as I'm sitting
there in the foyer people are walking
backwards and forwards I don't know
who's a patient and who's a visitor or
whose staff just in playing clothes and
I felt certain people walk past me and I
was so
so strong that that evening I said to my
mother I think some of these people in
this your ward are demon-possessed and
her surpris me her response was no it's
all
biochemical and I did not believe her it
was too much of a real experience and
and so yeah since then I've also felt
that I'm glad you're bringing that up
because I think in today's culture with
the Medical Science World you know it's
like they're medicating that's basically
how you would mostly treat these kind of
things right um you know I wonder I've
always wondered how many of those cases
a real actual chemical lack or you know
are are are basically the demons
oppressing us even in that way pushing
the buttons in your brain and you know
releasing whatever imbalanced chemicals
and things like that I mean just you
know feeding it with pharmaka is not
necessarily the fix so you so you rais a
good point because how do you know if
it's biochemical or if it's demonic so
in Cambodia we assume it's demonic and
after ordering evil spirits out if
nothing happens then we send them to the
sake wood gotcha and so there's still a
place for that type of medical
discipline it's just and we've seen
people that were completely wild uh once
they're on the psy drugs they function
fine yeah but then I've seen people pych
drugs that are completely wild so the
drugs are not having any impact right uh
I was talking to a
psychologist from here in the states
about what is his response and he said
treat with sake drugs first deal with
demon second and I said why it's easier
to fix the problem if it's demonic MH
and he said doesn't cost anything he
said because the trauma you cause a
person if you insinuate they have evil
spirits in them is more serious than the
trauma you cause them if you give them
psych drugs so that makes no sense
whatsoever because it's like you know I
you want to know the root of the problem
it it does make sense in that you don't
want to cause trauma to a person now in
Cambodia to be put on psych drugs is
more traumatic than to have evil spirits
in you because evil spirits are everyday
things people get possessed all the time
and and so for me to go in and deal with
evil spirit
first uh it they're fine with that
they're fine with that whereas if I send
them to the psych ward then there's some
uh Shame about having to take psych
drugs so it's different but I do believe
that many people here in the United
States and in other developed countries
who are onsy drugs could be living a
life of freedom without them if they
found freedom in
Christ so I I want to go back to
something you said earlier you were
talking about uh burning
items when we were dealing with this
craziness in our home uh my mom and I
were advised you should burn the bad
books like the Harry Potter books but I
I always wondered why can't we just
throw it out why do we have to burn
it in the Bible I think it's the bereans
when they heard the go gospel preached
they gaed all their witchcraft books and
I think you could say Harry Potter books
were witchcraft oh yeah and they burn
them in the street uh I think it's it's
a visual sign to neighbors and to the
spirit world that you're done with this
yeah right it's not coming back from the
you know the the the Flames yeah it
can't be passed on to somebody else
either you know yeah when uh I was
getting more involved in this Pastor
Daniel Walters who was mission president
of the Cambodia Adventist Mission at the
time he told me a story that had
happened in Borneo where somebody had a
spirit ring and they decided they were
done with it and so they they buried it
and the next day it was back on their
next to their bed where they'd normally
leave it and so they threw it in the
river and the next day it was back there
next to their bed wow so finally they
burned it and although the ring was
still functionally a ring uh it stopped
coming back I mean that sounds like Lord
of the Rings right wasn't the story like
they're supposed to throw it into the
fire I mean that's what bothers me about
movies that people don't really
recognize these are real scenarios these
are real situations and it's like you
see these in the movies it's just fake
it's in the movies that's I think that's
what the devil loves to do show you
something fake over here because he's
trying to smoke screen you about what's
really going on and and not only that
like you show something real and people
think it's fake but at the same time if
it happens to your life nobody will be
that surprised right you know it numbs
you to the ex shows like Lucifer and
whatever and and you know all this kind
of stuff if a zombie apocalypse happens
you're just preparing people yeah for
when it happens I have a theory about
zombie movies that we should tackle
someday I seriously think that that is
like dehumanizing right people that are
dead right the Bible talks about we
should be dead to sin therefore no
longer nothing it's not me it's Jesus
that lives in me right and they are
programming people to think that if
you're dead you're a zombie I had a
another young lady come to me she was in
her teens she was having epileptic fits
and she said said that the epileptic
feds began after she'd played on a
spirit Stone this is a stone where
people would make offerings but as a
small kid she she just played on it for
fun not realizing and then she started
getting these fits afterwards
and when she came to me they were like 3
months apart she'd only have them every
now and then but she came to ask me to
pray for her she felt that it was
demonic and so I I told her I will order
the evil spirit of epilepsy out of you
but if you don't get well go to the
hospital and get drugs right so I prayed
over her and she left and over the
coming months the fits got more and more
frequent until they were daily and she
came back to me and said can you pray
for me
again and I said well I told you if I
prayed for you and I ordered the spirit
out then if it keeps going go to the
hospital and she said yeah but you
believe but I didn't believe I've been
studying the Bible and now I believe can
you pray over me again so I did and she
never had another fit after that wow
that's that's
mindblowing so the devil will mimic
medical problems sure so not only
psychiatric problems but other issues
isues uh I had a lady that was she came
to me she couldn't walk she was having
problems with demons and and being
crippled I don't know if she actually
Associated being crippled with uh the
demons but she was crippled in the right
leg and she
um she she was not Christian she knew
nothing about God she had tried the
witch doctors in fact she told me that
one time when they were chanting over
her she coughed up three snakes and they
slithered away we were talking about
that whe they real or not I don't know
if they were real or not but she
believed that they were real oh wow and
so we we said okay we want to tell you
about Jesus the one who can set you free
uh and immediately the evil spirits took
control of her so this crippled lady
who's in her 50s now it takes six young
guys to hold her down oh wow so she's
super strong and no longer crippled well
over a two we period we work with her uh
a number of EV Spirits left
her she actually asked me to go to a
house and burn the spirit shelves that
she had set up in her house to try to
appease the spirits so these problems
would go away so she's sleeping in our
classroom and then afternoon my wife is
teaching the students the lay students
about health and I had gone with this
lady's husband to their house it was
about 20 M away in out in the
Villages and so we get GA the stuff
together to burn it and she wakes up in
the classroom sweat just running down
her crying out they're burning me
they're burning me wow and as I check
later it's at the same time as what
we're actually burning this stuff oh wow
and my wife and the students gathered
around her and the spirits that were
associated with the spirit shelves left
her but there was one more spirit that
didn't leave her uh and when the spirit
took control of her I watched her spin
around like a ballerina on her crippled
leg oh wow and
finally uh I I was trying to find what's
the reason the spirit is there by come
talking with her when she's in her right
mind and she was telling me about how
her teenage daughter had drowned and she
felt responsible because she wasn't
there to help her and so she had had
this guilt um because she had not being
there for her daughter when she needed
her like trauma as well maybe or well
yeah I guess it's trauma
her teenage daughter died and she feels
she's responsible for that M and so we
helped her to find Freedom in Christ to
be delivered of this guilt that she has
and after that the spirit never came
back wow but not only did the spirit not
come back she was able to walk fine wow
and so again we can see evil spirits can
cause physical problems and in the Bible
we see that somebody with a shriveled up
arm Jesus cast out the spirit their arms
is fine someone who's bent over uh Jesus
casts out the spirit they're fine so not
all physical maladies are from natural
causes and the de demons can do this to
deceive yeah so that's interesting in
the paralytics case right your sins are
forgiven what's easier for me to say get
up take your bed and walk or your sins
are forgiven like like I mean and then
Jesus says go and sin no more right
right right so you wonder um you know a
lot of times are we kind of contri to
some of these things maybe you know
maybe I'm I'm sure there's very real
people who are born paral paric and and
you know or has some accident or
something like that I'm not discount
counting that but Jesus says heal and
cast out evil spirits so there's two
different things that we call told to do
I I remember I went to a faith Camp by a
really nice Ministry called Jesus for
Asia where you're associated with them
you're a
missionary and uh you were speaking on
this and you were shing how some people
have actually experienced trauma just
like this L like a form of trauma that
causes the spirits to either harass or
possess right as another cause of it so
rape physical violence or even being
involved in and seeing physical violence
like in a war that sort of thing um we
call it pro post-traumatic injury right
but often that becomes a channel through
which demons can enter and work and so
people need to find Freedom in Christ uh
in order to be delivered of that and no
longer have the the symptoms that are
coming because of that I find that
really difficult to deal with because
you know I'm thinking if someone has had
a really tough life and they have had
trauma and and I just want to ask this
question because I think somebody else
at home might have this question why
would God allow for someone to get
possessed when they've already had a
really tough life and they not like they
just like oh I'm just going to practice
magic it's like no I've been raped or
something and now I'm dealing with this
you
know Satan claims to be Prince of this
world and I think God has
to give him a certain amount of Freedom
so that he can show what he's really
made of and how evil he really is and
but God if somebody will come to God for
help God will always help them
person that's right and so a lot of
people are victims of Satan if we're not
in God's Camp we're in Satan's camp and
Satan will do whatever he likes to those
that are his uh but if we're in God's
Camp Satan's going to harass us trying
to get us to change sides to blame God
because he's not helping us yeah he's
trying to find a way to frustrate or you
know you had this terrible thing
happened to you and you know he gives
you all these Alternatives outside of
God for alleviating that pain right just
numb it
you know have a addiction into something
else you know or fall prey to you know
if you're raped going into something
that deals with that situation and and
and further the problem worse he's
constantly trying to like probably numb
out that um experience when what I'm
hearing from you is just like Jesus
wants to take that thing and then give
you a new heart new mind new body in the
in the way of just healing yes but
also sometimes God
I think he wants to be proud of his
faithful people and if we look at the
story of Job we see God bragging about
job and Satan says let me do some stuff
to him and we'll see if he's still
faithful and I think even today God
likes to brag about his faithful people
and so sometimes those who
are one with Christ get harassed and I
experienced this one time where we were
doing a Deliverance session we been
fasting and uh we were praying over two
particular people that had come to us
for help and I lost all my strength and
so I told my students you continue I'm
going home and I rode my motorcycle home
short distance I couldn't drive straight
I was so
weak I laid down and I was in pain and I
realized this was a demonic attack and I
felt that this was similar to job's
experience so I spent that day in pain
praising God wow because it's like I
want God to have the victory not Satan
wow amen what a what a revolutionary way
to look at the problem and and so in the
evening it's was time to take a shower I
dragged myself downstairs out to the
well we at that stage we bed at an open
well and uh I took a scoop of water and
I P it on my head and it was miraculous
as it flowed down me every part that the
water touched was like normal again wow
so by the time my feet were wet I'm full
of energy again wow and it's like wow
God obviously said to Satan okay you
lost that reminds me of the symbol of
water in the Bible baptism is literally
dying yourself and giving yourself to
Jesus so that's really interesting I was
thinking of as you were mentioning job
last night I went to a prayer meeting at
our church and we're studying through
the Book of Revelation the Pastor said
something so fascinating INR
Christianity uh and this is in the
scriptures back us up we have uh as we
come to Jesus we have justification just
as if you've never sinned Jesus you come
to him you give your life to him and he
says okay you're Justified then we have
sanctification it's the whole life of
Jesus wanting to cleanse us from our sin
forgive us to change us right and then
we have glorification which is when
Jesus returns the second coming and
those who have been faithful to him will
go to heaven the pastor is pointing out
um where you have uh the story of uh
Zechariah 3 with Joshua the high priest
standing before the angel of the Lord
Angel capital A it's Jesus and Satan is
like well look at all he's done and he
has filthy rags and Jesus says go and
put clean Rags on him that's
justification then we have the story uh
in Jude nine where there's but the Jude
n talks about Satan wanting to hold
Moses back from you know he was going to
be he was claiming him he was claiming
him he was Jesus wanted to raise Moses
from the dead to take him to Heaven
which is why in the New Testament we see
Moses with Elijah and Jesus right Jude n
talks about this and again what does
Jesus say I rebuke you Satan he said the
same thing with Joshua I rebuke you
Satan right job he did not he said okay
you're allowed to do this so we have
um we have Moses with glor ification
right we have Joshua with justification
and job
sanctification it is in our life that
God allows these things to happen but
the Bible says everything works for the
good to those who love God and by by the
way if if you read the verses underneath
that about how God says um everything
works for the good to those that love
God the same process is pointed out
justification sanctification
glorification MH so sanctification this
is where we're at these things are
allowed to happen but for our
good I got one more story before we end
here that you and I talked about I think
the first time I actually met you and
I'm curious about it you don't have to
talk about it if you don't want to but
there was a lady that ate a piece of pie
or cake and got possessed what okay so
this is stay away from the cake this is
the lady that's some bad cake oh yeah so
this is the lady that could speak in
tongues okay and could curse and tell
the future so as a teenager she was an
orphan and she was basically working as
a servant in somebody's home and these
rice and banana cakes had been sent to
the family they had come from a Buddhist
temple and they had been blessed in the
Buddhist Temple and so there was some
left over at the end of the meal and so
she's cleaning up she ate it and when
she ate it that's when the evil spirits
first started speaking in tongues
through her isn't that crazy and she
said for the two following days all she
did was speak in tongues I I wonder Tim
so when this happened was that lady like
in the practice of worshiping these gods
or was she a genuine Christian or she
wasn't Christian at that stage yeah see
I think that's the difference too
because because I do believe that God
will protect us in our ignorance you
know I don't think that if you I mean it
depends on the person the situation
maybe but if you are told fully ignorant
to something then God's not going to be
like oh yeah I allow the demons to come
in you know I
think there's protection so in it was in
1 Corinthians 10:28 but if any man say
unto you this is offered in sacrifice
unto Idols eat not for his sake that
showed it and for the conscience sake
for the Earth is the Lord's and the
fullness thereof yeah I I I think I
agree with you though I'll have to look
that verse up as well um there might be
one in there that that talks about you
know even if it is worth you know offer
to idols and stuff like this that
doesn't have power over you but I'll
have to I'll have to look into that well
we can see from this example it's still
it still happens oh yeah right oh yeah
not only with food but also items like
you know the Harry Potter books or the
interesting the associations and and you
know so to wrap this up Tim um I really
appreciate you having a conversation
with us about this topic and um you know
there might some people out there that
are maybe baffled with I don't know what
to do my child is out of control um so
give us a little bit of advice give us a
little step real quick like what do you
do if you suspect what should they go
and find a pastor somebody to pray can
anybody do this what would you do well I
think as Christians we are all called to
do Deliverance but obviously we must be
right with Christ ourselves good point
and
uh as far as calling a pastor that would
be good if you can find a pastor that is
comfortable with dealing with this yeah
there's a lot of pastors I've actually
heard will not show up at a house if you
say there's some demon in there what mhm
I mean I'm sure it's a fearful thing and
if you got things in your life yeah but
if you're were a pastor you would assume
they have that Faith you would assume
right but but you know but you can if
you're the parent of a child you have
some authority to claim the black of
Jesus on your child's beh this is
underneath your care yeah yeah um and
you can pray asking God to break the
power of the evil spirits claiming the
blood of Jesus I can tell another quick
Story one of the mission workers in
Cambodia his child every night would
wake up at 10:00 screaming as if they
were seeing horrific things and various
he'd had various pastors pray over them
uh but he was attending a camp meeting
at our place and he came to me and said
can you pray over my child because I
believe that the holy spirit is with you
and it's like I was a little skeptical
because like you've already had other
pastors pray but I said okay I'll come
and so we prayed over the child and I
claimed the blood of Jesus to break the
authority of any evil spirits that are
harassing this child and from then on
they slept peacefully and they didn't
wake up at 10:00 every night wow um so
yeah we need to exercise The Authority
that we have in Christ but we must be in
Christ amen and uh there are some
materials that are helpful and a group
of 7day Adventist uh Deliverance
practitioners met a number of years ago
in bin Springs and worked on a
Deliverance manual for 7even day
Adventists beautiful and the manual is
called finding freedom in Jesus and I
believe we'll put the the link to get
that as a free pdf uh in the in the
destion in the description yeah awesome
and also if people want to look into
your ministry ask you to come you you
clearly go around the world and speak on
these kind of topics so you know if you
would like him to come to your church
and and speak on these issues or you
want to see more material where can they
find you um I think it's good if you put
my email address in we'll do that and
Link description below yes cool and uh
thank you Mr Tim and we are extremely
blessed by this conversation I hope you
guys were as well please like And
subscribe um we like to talk about
things that you know maybe potentially
there's not a lot of information out
there on that so if you have a
suggestion something you want us to
tackle we want to hear about it in the
comment section please feel free to
reach out to us if you have questions
and things that we cannot answer maybe
we can pass on your email address or you
can email Tim directly um how to go
about um dealing with these things but
um remember this out of this
conversation be covered by the blood of
Jesus amen you have authority over these
people God's giving us authority over it
but we need to confess we need to go
into that situation covered by the blood
of Jesus so um hopefully that will give
you some confidence and some um some
guidance on even how to begin this
process but prayer prayer and prayer the
entire time that you are experiencing
and and and wanting to cast these out
and pray without ceasing pray without
ceasing you the name of Jesus they
cannot stand the name of Jesus another
really good thing to do is sing and sing
um things with promises in them sing
songs scripture songs recite scriptures
that that that that God has said so just
do a quick Google we live in an amazing
day and age you can you everybody's got
a phone ask your phone hey Siri give me
all the scriptures that that are
promises right here we got a scripture
song Channel Now go to YouTube and
search for at the sign at bible
scripture songs and every single week we
upload new scripture songs for you
awesome and another thing that you can
do is you can wear some of our awesome
t-shirts that we've created lightwear
shop with Bible texts on them maybe that
protects you I don't know I'd like to
think so that's probably a Shameless
plug for you to go and buy those
t-shirts but um we hope that you guys
were blessed and uh we hope we'll see
you again next
week J
and he for you
is the pillar in the temple of my God
and he shall go out no more I will ride
on him the name of my
[Applause]
God shall
M by Shall run not
I pray alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of
God all right I can do this
[Music]
all
right there are conventional ways of
sharing the gospel but some may need a
different way of doing things um never
mind a way that gets the message out
with
confidence wow cool shirt what's the
mean oh thank you you know we're all
made with a unique fingerprint but we're
all God's artwork wow where'd you get
it lightwear wear your Witness
[Music]